Thank you very much for inviting me here
and I'm glad to share my dream to work.
Um so I will first start with an
introduction to data simulation just to
provide you with some background. Then
I'll try to cover these three topics. Um
bridging idealized and operational
models conditioning compment network and
assimulative cod inference. So these
three topics may sounds like separated
but actually they have tight
connections.
So um first this bridge model will
provide us a lot of this high quality
high resolution data set and this data
set will help us build new digital
systems and these digital systems will
help us do e efficient data simulation
and in quantification.
Then about this color inference um they
will ask will help us to understand
these what iff scenarios and actually
this is also an important question for
these digital twins and simulative col
inference will also help us to answer
these attribution and predictability
questions and will help us to solve
these tipping points extreme events and
all these topics will be very helpful to
build these new bridging models. So I'll
try to emphasize each point one by one
but I also try to provide the links
between these different aspects.
So first a quick introduction to data
simulation.
So what is data simulation? So data
simulation seeks to optimally combine a
numerical model with observations to
improve data estimation results. So why
should we do data simulation? Of course,
the model is typically very chaotic and
has uncertainties
while the observations are not perfect
as well because they contain noise and
they are often available only for a
subset of state variables. So basically
we have two things and either of them is
perfect but we try to combine them to
make results much better.
So um historically data simulation was
developed in the field of numerical
weather prediction and these systems are
highly chaotic
um where future states are very
sensitive to the initial conditions and
this is known as a butterfly effect and
therefore an accurate initialization is
extremely important for the scale for
forecast.
So here I show a very simple example
which is this loren sexist model. It is
a nonlinear model but it's only like
three dimensional system. So from the
figure here you can see and this blue
curve is just one realization from the
system and this is for the x variable
and you can also see this red curve
which is almost the same as this blue
curve from beginning but I try to
perturb the initial condition by
only.1%.
So you can see at the beginning these
two curves they overlap almost overlap
each other but at certain point maybe
around time 20 or 15 they start to
diverge and in the second panel here you
can see the error between these two
curves and in the y-axis actually I use
a log scale. So you can see from maybe
12 to 20 this linear increase of the
error but because I use a log scale in
y-axis the error groups actually is
exponential right so this tells us if we
have some small perturbation at the
beginning then for these chaotic systems
this error can be amplified
significantly afterwards which also
means you know we have to make sure we
have good initial condition to guarantee
a relatively long range forecast.
So of course you know initialization
does not just mean we try to den
noiseise it will also help us do many
other things. So for example usually in
practice we only have these sparse
observations like we have observations
at a few greater points but in order to
run a high resolution model we have to
make sure our initial condition covers
everything. So basically we have to use
data simulation to do some interpolation
to get initial condition at every grid
point from larger scale to small scale.
And similarly you know for some systems
maybe we only have these partial
observations. For example for the ocean
we may get good observations at the
surface but we have no observations for
the deep ocean. But when we run this
entire model we have to know the state
for both the surface and the deep ocean.
So we have to use data simulation and
observations from the surface to recover
the state in the deep ocean. Then we can
run the entire system to do the
forecast.
So of course nowadays data simulation is
very useful for many other tasks like
the sequential state summation parameter
estimation and the post-processing of
data and uncertainty quantification.
So mathematically this data simulation
is quite simple and straightforward.
Let's say we have the state variable we
use u to represent it and we also have
this partial and noisy observation. We
use this V to represent it. So basically
data simulation provides a statistical
state which means our result will not
just be a number but it will be a
distribution.
So the underlying principle of this data
simulation is given by this famous
baying theorem. So we have this
so-called pry distribution which is a
distribution based our pry knowledge um
which can come from a model or come from
any knowledge we have. Usually we draw
our model forward to get a distribution
and the reason is a distribution because
the model is very chaotic and turbulent.
So you try to use a distribution to
cover all possible range of the state.
While this likelihood it tells us uh how
consistent our observations is with the
model. So it's a conditional
distribution of this observation given
the model state.
Their product is called the postal
distribution and that is a distribution
we want to use as a data estimation
solution. So essentially it's a state
estimation of this u but it is given the
observations.
So the poster distribution integrates
information from the prior and from the
likelihood. Basically it combines
information from the model and
observations. But how to incorporate the
information depends on the uncertainties
in this prior and it likelihood. So I
show a very simple figure here. You can
see this blue curve again it's a prior
distribution and this black one is
likelihood. And in this case they have
similar um uncertainties here. And
therefore when we have posterior
distribution basically we try to pull
the posterior in the middle right we
don't have any biases towards either of
them but in the second case you can see
this prior distribution which is in
green has a smaller uncertainty than
this black occur which likelihood and
therefore we will trust this prior more
than the likelihood. So our posterior
will be closer to this p distribution.
So depending on when the state summation
and observation incorporation made data
simulation can be classified as
filtering and smoothing. So filtering
uses only the path information to
improve the initialization of the
real-time forecast. And there are many
filtering method. The most famous one is
called common filter. Comma filter works
for the linear and gaussing systems. And
it has closed and formula. So we can
easily run these um equations without
using any numerical method. But of
course in practice our systems are
usually highly nonlinear, highly
non-gausing. So we have to rely on this
ensemble comma filter or particle filter
to get some numerical approximation.
So on the other hand we also have this
method called smoothing. So smoothing
estimates the state at a given time by
utilizing the observations from both the
past and future. And the main purpose of
using this smoothing is to do a
post-processing of the data. So it's
kind of like a interpolation but you
don't use like a linear or quadratic
rule to do the interpolation. You use
the dynamical information to tell the
system how to do the interpolation.
So there are many key challenges in this
data simulation especially for high
dimensional systems. Um they include
like sparse observations and high
computational and storage cost. and this
inherent model errors and sample errors
using limited ensemble sizes.
So here I show a very quick example of
how data summation can solve many of the
problems I mentioned previously and this
is a work led by my former student Jeff
Coington. So we study this um CI ice
problem. If you can see this red box
that is called the marginal ice zoom and
you see a lot of these small pieces of
ice which are called the C ice flow foe.
So what we have here is like in June 26
and June 28 we can identify a lot of
these CIS flows but because of the cloud
we cannot see a lot of these flows in
June 27th.
But in order to give a complete data set
we have to apply some method to recover
the CS flows in June 27th.
Of course for the state of the arch
method people say hey we can use linear
interpolation. But then we think for a
second if this is a good method or not.
The answer is of course it's not right
because these CS flows they are driven
by the ocean field and ocean has a lot
of these addies which have this rotation
behavior. So if we use a linear
interpolation then you can see um we'll
miss the actual location of the CIS
flow.
So what we do here is we use data
simulation to build this dynamical
interpolation framework. So we run our
coupled system of atmosphere ocean and
CIS forward. Then we use the limited
observations of these CS flows to guide
our system than this data simulation.
So what we can get is because we have
this dynamical information so we can get
the right curvature of many of these
flows. So the distribution of the
curvature the distribution of the
angular displacement are closer to the
truth comparing with our empirical
forecast model.
And in addition, you know, although we
can observe the locations of the CIS
flows, we cannot observe the thickness
of the CS flows, right? Because these
are just images. But this thickness is
very important for the dynamics of CIS.
So we can augment our couple system by
including the thickness as additional
state variables. So we can estimate the
thickness here. And lastly, we can also
recover the ocean field because we have
this coupled system. If we know the
trajectory of the flow of the CI flow
field, we can recover the ocean dynamics
and uncertainty as well. So basically I
want to say here you know we can use
data simulation to do this interpolation
and we can quantify the uncertainty and
also we can estimate the parameters.
So now move on to the main part of my
talk. Um the first topic is about this
bridging idealized and operational
models and eventually we want to build
an explainable AI framework for earth
system emulators.
So why did we want to do this work? Um
because in reality we have different
models. We can roughly classify our
models into two categories. Um the first
one is called this idealized models.
They are usually lowdimensional
stochastic ODS or stoastic PDS developed
by applied mathematicians.
While on the other hand we also have
these so-called operational models. They
are usually like general circulation
models in atmosphere ocean science or
you try to think these are very
complicated models high resolution
containing a lot of features and are
very difficult to run.
So these idealized models um can
accurately characterize certain natural
processes. They are often used to
understand these larger scale physics
and they can perform time series or cost
the spatial temporal predictions. So
these are the advantages of these simple
idealized models.
However, these models only include a
subset of variables. you pick up a few
key variables and model them and they
are often limited to specific domains.
So they are like local models or very
large scale models.
On the other hand, these operational
models they are often high and they
incorporate many crucial variables and
they had a lot of these successful
results in the operational forecast.
However, bias is always persistent in
most of these models and especially
because these models very complicated.
So, it's very difficult for them to
capture these extreme events and
accurately reproduce statistical
properties.
So, we always want to improve these
operation models. But you know the
models are very complicated. If you try
to change a small part in this model
then very likely everything will be
changed and uh it's likely the system
will blow up or you can you can have a
lot of additional biases. So directly
modifying these models are very
difficult.
So usually you know um these are two
like separated communities like simple
models are claimed at least claimed to
provide guidance for building more
complicated models and simulations from
operation models are used to evaluate
the performance of simpler models. But
beyond these you know very obvious
connections and these different models
are often operate in isolation and the
communication between these different
modeling groups or even between these
different communities is very limited.
So there's a recent paper in this age
advances which highlights the importance
of this idealized models. It's a short
paper but it listed a lot of um
advantages of using simpler models to
help complicated models. So it's a nice
paper to take a look.
Okay. So um based on this motivation, so
we now try to bridge this model
hierarchy using the latent space data
simulation. And this work was led by my
posttopia um Benodafer and my student
Moser.
So what we are doing is the following.
So we have these two sets of models
simple models and operation models. And
we also have some so-called reanalysis
data which you can think as
observational data but they are very
limited especially in the atmosphere and
ocean science. We only have short
observational period.
So if we want to use only this operation
observational data to build like a
machine learning segment model that's
almost impossible.
So what we try to do is the following.
So we have these simple models and we
use these simple models to generate
these so-called pseudo observations
which are just like the output from
these simple models.
Then we build some machine learning
surrogate based on this operational
model data and we try to use these
surrogate models as a forecast model in
data simulation. And of course we know
they are not perfect because we have a
lot of issues in operation models. But
since we have this high quality data
from the idealized models, these pseudo
observations can help us guide the final
result. So basically we try to push the
forecast from the operational models to
go to the state of the simple model
output at least for those few variables.
Then since those few variables will be
corrected then this entire system will
have this input behavior.
Um we have to use this latent data
summation skie because um the operation
model is high resolution. It will take
forever if we join the original model
directly.
So of course this latent data simulation
idea is not completely new. There are
some existing very nice work on latent
data simulation. Um however this
standard latent data simulation method
they just project model forecast and
observations to a shared latent space to
reduce the cost. Um but in our situation
because we have these two very separated
model hierarchies our simpler models
compared with a complicated model we can
only have these sparse observations
which means the output in the simple
model only have a few dimensions a few
can mean a few hundred.
So therefore in order to put this
specific situation into this latent data
simulation framework we build this new
augmented latent data simulation. So the
goal is to seek a reduced dimension
latent space based on the outer port
from the operation models. But at the
same time we also try to maximize the
correlation between this latent space
representation of state variable and
these sparse pseudo observations from
idealized model. So the reason we try to
maximize the correlation is we
eventually want to do data simulation.
So if we just try to compress the data
then maybe the latent space has nothing
to do with the observational physical
space then data simulation at this
likelihood will not help us. So then
this idealized model will not be useful
in um pushing the forecast towards the
right state. So imposing this maximum of
the correlation very important in our
framework.
And on the other hand we know we have
some limited real analysis data. We also
want to use this kind of information to
further correct the forecast biases and
therefore we use this so-called
colloquial learning and we try to
gradually introduce estimated realis
data into the training process.
So we call the result the bridging model
and this bridging model can efficiently
generate many highquality synthetic data
set which can mimic nature and they can
help us to study extreme events and they
can also provide a training data set for
many a machine learning tasks including
improving the digital twins and uh
importantly because now we incorporate
these two sets of models then we can
provide a pathway for enhanced community
collaboration.
So I will show one important
applications to the ocean science here
and we will significantly advance the
simulation of the so-called onino sauce
osellation or ENSO which is the most
predominant interanual variability in
our earth system and it has impact of
both the global and local weather and
climate patterns as well as a lot of
extreme events.
So believe it or not and despite these
advances in this climate modeling,
simulating this still remains challenges
because of its spatial temporal
diversity and complexity features and
these features means we have different
types of oino events. They have
different strengths and different
lengths of durations and they have a lot
of extreme events. They have multi-year
events. So all these features make this
entire feature very complicated.
So most of the state-of-the-art
operational models cannot even generate
these two types of onino. Two types
means we have central pacific events and
the eastern pacific events. But these
are like the very basic features. But
you know most of operation models cannot
even get these features
and all the operation models have
statistical biases like they they are
not good at capturing extreme events or
some noning statistical features.
So among all these operation models, the
two best operation models are the CSM2
developed by UNAR and this GFDL CM2.5
developed by the Princeton GFDL lab.
However, these models still have
problems in reproducing many observed
features of ENS which I'll show next
page.
So on the other hand you know um apart
mathematicians like us so we build a lot
of simpler models.
So we
build an intermediate coupled model it's
a stoastic model and this model can
capture this ano complexity and the
nonausing statistics along the equator.
So it's like a one-dimensional model
just in the x direction
but it can capture all these statistics
very similar to the observations
and of course the downside is it's a
simpler model we cannot get the features
of equator and we only contain some of
the variables and some variables like
the subsurface temperature from
operation models cannot be captured
using this model but at least I want to
show like this figure you can see the
first panel is from the reanalysis
observation data
This x-axis is the location, the
longitude and so latitude. Then the
y-axis is time. You can see these
different events. Red means, blue means
liner. And you see some extreme events.
Some events happening in the central
Pacific, some in Eastern Pacific. And
this is a free run of our model. You can
see extreme events, ninear event, some
central Pacific event, some east Pacific
event. And you see this probability
density function in the two most
important regions. The central Pacific
distri sorry central pacific
distribution is specific distribution
and this no variation of the variance
also can be captured very well. Right?
So um we also have another even simpler
model we call that conceptual model. Um
it has only six dimensions. It's like
six dimensional stocasts.
So any KU student you know in their
first or second year can easily run this
model. But this model can also capture
these diversity features at least in a
very large scales.
So now I want to show the result. Um
here you see three columns. So the left
column is a result from this CSM2 one of
the best um operational model. In the
middle that's a gold reanalysis data. Um
you can treat that as a reference the
truth the observations and the right
colon is our bridging model results.
So the contour so the shading here is
the C surface temperature or SST which
is a indicator of the ENSO. The contour
is a wind zonal wind. And in the second
row here the shading is a C surface
height of thermocline which is H and the
contour is a subsurface temperature.
Um what I show here is the variance over
time at each longitude latitude grid
point. So this is one of the basic
indicator to see you know if any model
can capture the only features. So you
know even if you are not familiar with
the background you can tell this first
column is very different from the second
column but the third one is pretty close
to the first one right and remember our
observation the pseudo observation from
the ideal model is only along the
equator and it only contains the SST and
edge no son wind no subsurface
temperature but with this latent space
data simulation we can actually recover
all these field quite
And we can also get these different
onino events which are very similar to
nature. We can see the extreme events in
the eastern pacific and moderate event
in the eastern pacific leninia central
pacific event and this mix event.
So here we show the statistics the
probability density function in know4 is
a central pacific region know3 is
eastern pacific and 3.4 is between
central and eastern pacific. But overall
we can see the red curve which is from
our bridge model is very similar to the
blue curve which is our real analysis
data. This black curve is from CSM which
has a very large bias
and uh on the right here you know we use
this sixdimensional stoastic OD and we
still we can correct the SST and the
wind biases by a lot. right now the
variance of SST is located or pushed
towards eastern Pacific.
So I also want to mention that um this
framework can provide us a physics
assistant and digital twin framework. So
usually we know when we have data twins
we want to test this what if scenarios
basically want to say we change the
forcing then what will happen to the new
scenario. So here because we have these
two models we can actually um do this
what if scenario on the simpler models
because we know the entire dynamics then
we assimilate that to the more
complicated models to get this four
field what if scenario test
and we apply this to this. So in the
middle uh in the middle column here it's
a current situation and in the left
column here that's a case when we try to
decrease the worker circulation and in
the right column we have this
acceleration of worker circulation.
Basically the left column is the past
situation right column is the future
situation and these are very consistent
with people have discovered using the
knowledge and some potential
observational data. But we can do this
very easily just using our idealized
model. Then we do data simulation.
So okay I will move on to the second
topic. This conditional Gaussian
coopermanman network. Um it's a unified
framework um for modeling forecasting
data simulation and quantification. So
eventually want to build a stoastic
digital tooling.
So um currently you know machine
learning is a very important and popular
tool for data simulation. And the
existing machine learning methods for
data simulation can be broadly um
grouped into two methods. One is called
this end to end machine learning method.
Basically you have an input of the
state. You have this black box machine
learning. You have outport as your
posterior distribution but usually just
a posterior mean. So of course this is a
very straightforward idea and it works
pretty well in many situations and
however you know the challenges are very
obvious. how to build this map for high
dimension systems and how to effectively
quantify the uncertainties beyond just
posterior mean.
And the second method is we still keep
this basing framework but we replace the
traditional physicsdriven forecast model
by a machine learning ser forecast model
right so you don't change this framework
so you can still get the same output as
the traditional method but you can
accelerate your calculation in a
forecast stage um of course the
challenges are this still in this
ensemble method right you still need to
do a lot of empirical tunings for
localization for the coarance inflation
So um what motivates what motivate us to
build this condition gingment network is
the following. So in contrast to purely
machining method we are thinking about
maybe we can leverage specific yet
general enough stoastic model structures
to help us substantially enhance the
accuracy and efficiency of non data
simulation. So in other words, we try
not to just use machine learning, but we
try to integrate the information of some
known stoastic systems into the machine
learning framework. So it's kind of like
a hybrid strategy with some physical
knowledge or mathematical knowledge from
stoastic systems and machine learning.
So also there's a strong need to develop
like a unified framework which can
capture the modeling of complex systems
performing accurate forecast and
conducting efficient data simulation
simultaneously. So we can form this
entire loop so we can apply that to
digital twins. But meanwhile we must
make sure we can effectively quantify
the uncertainties in the state
estimation. So if we can do all these
things together then we have a closed
loop system then we can use this machine
based method to um to accelerate the
forecast and to assimilate the state.
So this work was led by um a student who
um tinu and I co-advis
and my current student PhD student J.
So what we are doing is the following.
So let's say we have a set of PDS or
stocasta PDS um partial UT partial t= m
u tutor and uh let's do a special
temporal discretization of this system
in order to fit into the you know real
world application. So space and time are
both discretized and we use this state u
to denote the state special temporal
discretization and this g is the
discretization of this m. So both m
energy are highly nonlinear and the n
and n plus one are the current and
future time instant.
So in many cases we know the
measurements um are only partial of the
state variables just like I said maybe
we can measure the large scale grid
points but there are a lot of these
small scale features we cannot measure
directly right so that's why it's very
natural we try to split this entire
state variables into two parts U1 and U2
and U1 is observed variable U2 is the
unobserved variables
so correspondingly we can rewrite this
system into two equations and G1 and G2
are both highly nonlinear just from this
G but we try to write the dynamics of U1
and U2 separately.
So this condition Gingerman network um
try to change this entire system to a
different stoastic differential
equation.
So we still keep this U1 variable here
and on the right hand side we have this
F_sub_1 which is a fully nonlinear
operator of this U1 and similarly for
this G1 but we try to change this U2 we
find a nonar map and move that to this
variable V here on the right hand side
we still have this strong nonlinear
dependence of this U1 here and here but
we try to now change the dependence of
this V to be a conditionally linear
system. So overall it's still highly
nonlinear because u and v can interact
but you know if we are given the
trajectory of this u1 then this v is
conditionally linear and we have some
additional stoast noise here.
So f_sub_1 f_sub_2 g1 and g2 they
contain some neural operators in
addition to the no physics physical
structures from the original pds.
So you may wonder why we want to do this
right? Okay. So I will show the
advantages later but before that I want
to say we have clear mathematical
justifications for this condition
Gaussian nonlinear systems
and we had a paper um with I had a paper
with my with my Ph advisor Andy Maida in
2018 actually that's a review paper
which is like 100 pages long and we have
um maybe 80 to 100 examples showing many
of the dynamical systems um will fit
into this framework or fit into the
continuous in time analog and these
examples are lens models, gel equation,
boo equation, physicum model, sr and
many ocean atmosphere models. So believe
it or not many of the system you have
used belong to this framework. So that
provide us a good physical or
mathematical justification of taking
this form as our condition gingum
network scheme.
So essentially this CG can um transform
this general nonlinear system into a
highly nonlinear neuro differential
equations with these condition gaussian
structures.
However, you know, even though we call
it conditional linear condition going,
the marginal distributions of U1 and U2
as well as the joint distribution of U1
and U2, they are still highly nonlinear
and highly non-sing. And the reason is
very simple, right? Overall, you treat
them as a entire state variable. Then on
the right hand side, you see all these
nonlinear terms. So we can guarantee we
have nonlinear system and non-causing
distributions for every single variable.
And that's important because we don't
want to just completely do a Gaussian
approximation. So we'll miss extreme
lengths.
So one of the main reasons we try to
rewrite a system into this form is that
we can still keep a lot of nonlinear
interactions. But this kind of structure
will allow us to develop analytical
formula for nonlinear data simulation.
And the reason is very simple. We make
use of this conditional linear
structure. So we can have some closer
form to the data data simulation even
though the system itself is highly
nonlinear. And when we have closed cycle
formula that means we do not need to use
ensemble method and that's a huge
advantage because we can put this data
simulation laws into our training right
we have a closer form and we do not need
to have all these sampling issues. So we
just need to um add this additional data
summation laws into our system. So we
can train our neural network. Then we
can do both a forecast and data
simulation. And when we do data
summation we also have the instant
quantification. So that part is
automatically considered in this
framework.
So this CG can basically compensates for
the structure simplification from fully
nonlinear to conditional linear by
lifting the dimension of the system from
a theoretical viewpoint. And uh you can
think this is motivated by the Kman
theory, right? Because Kumman theorem
says you can always lift a dimension of
a system to a linear system for an
originally nonlinear system. But I do
want to point out one big difference
here. So in you know it's eventually it
will give you a linear system but here
we still end up with a highly nonlinear
system but just a conditional linear. So
we we have to say we just borrow some of
the ideas there but our system is very
different from the traditional coupman
theorem.
Um although we have um we have this
highdimensional system by design we can
always do a dimension reduction using
the autoenccoder or any other dimension
reduction method. So eventually we have
this lifting of the system then we do
this compression. So we try to make this
dimension of this V variable still
pretty low. So that can help us further
to do efficient data simulation.
And finally I want to point out that
even though the condition distribution V
given this U1 is Gaussian right um but
this condition distribution is in the
latent space when we project this V back
to the physical space U2 we have a
nonlinear map. So we are able to have a
non- gaussing distribution of this C2
and this non-sing distribution will be
potentially useful for us to quantify a
lot of these intermittency and extreme
events with this tails.
So I want to show a quick simple example
you know we deal with this
two-dimensional Navis equation and the
resolution of the simulation 128 square.
So we have we assume we have eight times
h observations it's regularly and
distributing in space.
So our condition gausing network can do
both a forecast and data simulation. Um
we compare our method with two sets of
methods. One is about this data
simulation or data simulation using the
standard ensemble comma filter with
localization and this very naive method
doing interpolation based on the no
observations. And on the forecast side
we compare CGK with DN CN and F neural
network.
Um in order to you know make sure it's a
fair comparison we assume the new
networks all have similar number of
hyperparameters.
So what you can see here on the top is
the result of the forecast. So the first
row is truth second is CGK. We have
similar behavior as this free neural
network and we did much better
performance compared with DN which kind
of diverge and even see the which have
different features.
While in the second part here it's a
data summation result top row is a
choose second is CG which is very
similar to a truth. ENCF is also very
similar to a truth. So if you look at
the error basically you have similar
errors compared with INF. This
interpolation didn't work well because
you only have sparse observations.
Um but I also want to point out it's not
just about the computational accuracy
it's also about the computational
efficiency right so we compare our data
simulation um speed with ensemma filter
and we can see we can gain like 600
times you know compare compared with
ensemma filter for burgers equation and
for the navis equation has 300 faster
you know compared with and this is very
important because when we do the
real-time state estimation or sequential
show the estimation. We do want to make
sure we can run these codes very fast.
So we have applied this CG can to many
other interesting problems like we try
to recover the deep ocean and the
topography like the seamounts. Um we
also use that to do lounge data
simulation based on the um lounge
traces. We have also done some
theoretical studies when we try to
incorporate memories and we have some
online learning algorithm to gradually
correct its error.
So in my last 10 15 minutes I will talk
about this assimulated codo inference
method.
So what is cod inference? So I'm sure
you have heard about this um codo
inference these two words many many
times. So this coin influence determines
cause and effects relationship between
variables in complex systems and it's
very fundamental in model identification
policy development and evaluation as
well as decision making.
So this call inference has a huge field
and there are many different methods but
usually you can you know categorize them
into these two groups. One is called
datadriven method and the most famous
one is this grand you know code
inference and you know grand the Nobel
prize a few years ago and this nonlinear
version called transfer entropy. So all
these like datadriven or time series
methods you know they try to discover
the codal relationship um from time
series and they will provide you this
time average relationship. Basically it
will tell you hey y will contribute to z
x will contribute to z overall.
So it will not tell you at each time
instant you know X will contribute to Z
or Z will reversely contribute to X.
There also some like model based method
um for example the information transfer
or people use the dis response. So these
are very useful method to incorporate
some physics but the thing is um you
know they can only handle very short
range in time and for most of these
method you have to compute not just the
PDF the distribution but the derivative.
So that makes the calculation really
difficult because you have to make sure
you have enough samples ensembles at the
tail so you can take the derivative and
therefore this method um usually it's
very expensive or you can it can only
deal with low dimension systems.
So there are a lot of very important
issues in code inference. So one thing
is you know beyond this time average
relationship we may you know care a lot
about the so-called instantaneous call
inference because instantaneous calling
inference tells us at each time instant
how one variable will affect the other.
Maybe X will affect Z for now but for
next time instant Z will go back to
affect X. So we want to look at these
dynamic interactions between cause and
effect result variables and we want to
make sure you know this is time evolving
states
and equally important here to detect the
so-called inference range between
variables right we are not just
interesting in saying hey we want to say
x contribute to z want to say how far in
future x will affect z or how far
backwards from z to x that will be
affected. So this time range is
important for us to make a lot of
policies or prepare for the harmful
results.
And from a practical viewpoint um we
also care about some algorithm which can
deal with highdimensional systems
especially chaotic or turbulent systems
and we want to use maybe only the
partial observations because we may not
have access to all observations and want
to see how important is this uncertainty
in the code inference.
So based on this um I will try to
highlight all these topics um in the
simulated code inference framework.
So this work was led by my current um
PhD student Mario Andrew. And so this
assimilated col inference or ACI is a
inference framework that uses this
basing data simulation to reveal cause
and effect relationship.
So before I show the detail I want to
mention about some high level things. So
this ACI can identify this dynamical
codal interactions which means we look
at each time instant we can say if one
variable affects the other and maybe at
next time instant the other variable
will affect the current variable.
So there are several very important
features. One is that we do not require
observations of these candidate causes.
We only need observations of the of the
effect variables. This is important
because let's say we want to understand
which variable causes fluctuations at
the sea surface. So we know there must
be some variables in the deep ocean
which will you know contribute to the
surface but it's unlikely we will have
observations of deep ocean right we we
only have satellite images for the
surface.
So we do not require this candidate
course to be observed
and because we use data simulation so we
can accommodate some short data sets and
there are a lot of these very mature
data simulation tools. So our method can
be scaled to high dimensions
and importantly this ACI will provide
this online tracking of the codo rules
which may reverse intermittently and we
actually develop a mathematically
rigorous criteria for the cod inference
range meaning like in future how far in
future each contribution will have to
the effect variables.
So in this figure I try to illustrate
the like the big picture um without
touching too too many mathematical
details. So the idea is the following.
So we try to run data simulation in two
different setup.
So we have this x variable which is our
observation. Y is a potential cause of
this x. So first we use the time series
up to the current time instant. We do
this filtering to recover the state of
this y. So we get some distribution
right the observation is kind of noisy
and it is stoastic then we have some
turbulent model.
Then second you know we use the time
series of x not just up to the current
point but also up to the future point.
Then we do this data estimation again of
this y at this time t. So we try to
compare these two distributions from
filter and from smoothing. So if the
information in this smooth distribution
is more than the information from future
that means the future information um in
X will help us to reduce uncertainty and
reversely we can say this um Y will
contribute to the future state of this
X. This is more like using the inverse
problem viewpoint.
And this figure tells us you know we
want to look at this code inference
range not just going forward into the
future. If we go forward to the future,
that's more like a predictability study,
which is important. But we can also go
backwards, we try to find the
attribution of what causes this observed
event.
So in our paper, we use this so-called
relative entropy to measure the
difference between filter and smoothing.
So this is one of the most uh widely
used information criteria. But you know,
the framework can you know adjust to
other information criteria if you want.
So um how to compute this um code
inflence range it is something pretty
tricky. Um so let's say we denote this
capital t as a final time and a little t
as a current time instant. So we know
our chaotic autobian systems usually
have only finite effective inference
length right we cannot predict one year
of the weather from now.
So um we can actually um approximate the
actual smoother distribution by using
this um form. So the actual smoother
distribution will conditional on x from
zero to the final time instant capital
t. But at certain point t prime which I
just stopped because using further
future information will not help too
much. Just as I show in this figure, you
know this is full distribution, right?
There's a full information we can use
but maybe up to here that's enough. If
you use additional information that will
not help you get much better result.
So if we use information up to t prime
that is enough. Then we basically will
take the difference between this t prime
and the current time instant. Then this
length which is the length of this red
shading area that will tell us um the
code inference range right. Um but you
have noticed that this method depending
on this threshold which is very
subjective depending on how we prescribe
it and the issue is that you know
usually want to prescribe a small
threshold maybe 10 to the minus 5 but
what about 10 to the minus 7. So you can
see from this figure if I prescribe a
small threshold like 10 to 5 my code
inference range will be this long. But
if I just make a small change to 10 to
minus 7 then the coding range can be
even longer and this is highly sensitive
especially when this shown is very
small. So basically you have to be very
subjective telling hey it will you know
this effect will you know have last for
three days or five days depending on how
I define this. So this is very
subjective.
um in order to get an objective CIR the
coance range what we do is we try to
look at all the possibility of this. So
theoretically I mean so we can say hey
if we choose a large epone then what
will be the range? If I choose a small
what will be the range? So we try to
plot this curve which is a curve that
corresponds to the set as a threshold
and all possible range here and
eventually we do not take any point
along this curve but we try to take the
integration of this curve. So if it's
hard for you to understand you can just
think about a very simple stocast model
and uh we all know we have the so-called
autocorrelation function and decision
time right autocorre function measures
the dependence of two points in a
stoastic model and this decoding time
which is integration of autoquision
function gives just you just a number to
tell on average how long this memory
will last. So this subjective and
objective CS can be regarded as analog
of all the correlation function and
decolision time.
Um and of course we do not need to
repeatedly compute every single point
along this curve than we do integration.
We have designed a much simpler and fast
algorithm with some small approximations
um to efficiently help us to calculate
this co strength.
So I will show a very simple example
here. It's a two dimensional system um
where this x is what we observe y is the
potential cause of this x. So we only
have these two terms um in the nonlinear
form but they are very important. You
can see this is like a damping tuning x.
This gamma time y is a stochastic term.
We call that as stoastic damping because
if gamma time y is bigger than this dx
then overall the damping will become
positive. So you have exponential
increase right and this exponential
increase will generate some extreme
events but of course this exponential
increase cannot last forever because
when x becomes very large we have this
feedback term which will push y back to
a negative value. So that will kill the
extreme event.
So you can see in this panel a and I
have this um pink color curve which is
this x time series. You see a few of
these extreme events, right? And this
blue blue curve, just look at the curve.
So it is a time series of this Y. So
once Y exceedes some threshold and last
long enough, it will trigger this
extreme event.
So what I show in this second panel here
is this um asimated colon inference
matrix and you can see this just slight
slightly before this extreme event peak
this variable to Y2X has the strongest
codon inference link here which makes
sense because you trigger this extreme
events right and only when this Y
becomes very positive that will give
this strong peak. So it tells you you
know this Y is indeed the triggering
effect of this X. While here you also
see this like a horizontal lines. So
they are the code inference range. So
even though at this time instant the
contribution of Y to X is the most
significant because you can directly see
the result and actually this Y will
affect X to trigger this experiment will
happen much earlier. It's not like we
have to make wait until y becomes a very
large value. So x will be the outcome.
It starts when y started to grow, right?
But it will take some time for this x to
adjust to going into the extreme event
phase. So this happens much earlier. But
this is a good sign because that tells
us we can actually find attribution much
earlier for these extreme events. That
can help us to do some preparation when
we have these damage events happening in
nature.
Um so we have another linked paper
submit to some of JUQ. So we study um
this conditional ACI which means we may
not have just two sets of variables. We
have three sets and we only want to look
at the code relationship between two but
the three the third set of variable
exist. We also studied the
predictability and attribution using the
forward backward code inference range.
Here I only show the forward but we have
a backward version. We also look at the
tipping point. Now with this method we
can kind of distinguish the bification
driven tipping points and the noise
driven tipping points. We have some
applications to the mad judation on and
the wind and we can use this method to
identify the minimal reduce of the
models for complex systems. Basically
you kill all the link which tells you
they have very weak dependence. It's
kind of a sparse identification method.
So okay to summarize so I um try to
introduce the basic idea of data
simulation. Then I try to cover these
three different topics. So we develop
this bridging model which integrates
simple and complicated models. We can
use this model to efficiently generate a
lot of time series um or high resolution
data which can be useful for us to build
digital twining system. And in this
condition gingerman network we can see
we do data simulation UQ and the
forecast at the same time. So it forms a
closed loop. Then this assimilated code
inference will be useful to support both
of this bridge model and the ding and we
try to understand some mechanism by
using a coder inference.
So at the end I want to um acknowledge
my um team. So and they are all students
and posttos which contribute a lot to
the work and and especially TRI he's on
the job market he wrote all the code for
the condition causing network he's a
very mature research scientist now and I
list all the papers I mentioned in this
work the first is about bridging model
these two are the conditioning network
and these are the cold inference papers
so with this I want to say thank you for
listening to my talk and I look forward
to questions thank
Thanks for the wonderful talk, man. Um,
>> thank you.
>> Let me check.
>> Yeah. Uh, there is already one question
in the ch uh chat room. Please uh raise
your questions in the chat room. Um, so
the first question is from Nuning um
asking could you talk more details about
how to make the augmented datace in
slide eight for two types of data and
how
>> Yeah,
>> I'll go back.
Yeah, that's an excellent question.
Thanks for asking this. So, um, we first
project our operation model data to this
latent space. Then we augment that. So,
the new latent space is not just about
the compressing of data. It has a first
part which is from this um autoenccoder,
but we have a second part which is our
observational state variables from the
idealized model. Then when we design
this latent space, we use this
autoenccoder, right? So we have some
loss but we try to also include this
maximum of the correlation between these
two parts into a loss function. So loss
function not just try to minimize the
mean square error but it's a mean square
error minimization and the maximization
of the correlation.
I hope that answer the question.
>> Yeah uh uh did also uh answer your
question about linking them linking um
how how are these linked together in the
latent space? Sorry I missed that
question. Um
>> how are these in the latent space?
>> Uh they are linked together in the
latent space but uh
>> yeah yeah so we we do this autoenccoder
right. So we build this latent space but
you know traditional method you just try
to minimize the mean square error
between the output and input. So now
this is only part of our training loss.
So we use this correlation to link these
two parts in the latent space.
Uh so while we are waiting for the
audience to get us some false uh uh I
will jump to ask some questions but
please bear with me if it seems seems
straightforward. So I want to ask in the
CGKM framework um so if I understand
correctly the posterior distribution is
forced to be exactly Gausian.
>> Mhm.
So is it like do you believe all the
nonlinear OD or PD system would would be
okay with this uh assumption or is there
any mathematical limitations?
>> Very very good question. Thanks for
asking this because each time I give
this talk people ask this question you
know kind of similar. So I want to say a
few things. So first you know the system
itself is highly nonlinear and highly
non gaussing only the conditional
distribution is gaussing not marginal or
joint distribution right so if you look
at the state variable U1 and V they
themselves are highly non- gaussing
right that's the first point and the
second point is um yes the conditional
distribution of V given this U1 is
gaussing but remember this V is only in
the latent space when we map this back
to the physical space we have this
nonlinear map. So this gaussing variable
will become a non- gaussing variable. So
we can still capture all these extreme
events intermittency and other non-ging
features. Just we try to use a
conditional gausing structure in the
latent space to facilitate data
simulation but in the latent space you
know the state variable may not have a
clear physical meaning right um which
matters eventually will be the physical
variable. So we just try to you know use
this V as a bridge in the latent space
just for our computational efficiency.
>> I hope this answer your question.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Um
so may I can I can ask one more. Uh so I
want to ask a little like u conceptual
understanding about the idea about the
uh the
what is it called the the idealized
models and the bridging model.
>> Okay. So
yeah. So what I want to ask is is uh
maybe I miss it but is the bridging
model sign forecasting the dynamic uh
significantly faster than the operation
models.
>> Yes. Yeah. I didn't say this but you
know we try to run our model um on this
on example right. Yeah.
>> So um eventually we run like 40 years
because the 40 years is the length of
the real analysis period. So when we
have this bridge model, we use only like
8 minutes to get this 40 year data um
using our laptop. Um I don't know how
long exactly it will take to get this
operational model simulation for 40
years but um we can order the operation
models. It will take very long. It will
take maybe a few days. I don't know
exactly how long is but this must be a
few orders bigger than this 8 minutes.
And uh they have this outport from their
website. So you can download the data.
They generate the data for
140 50 years. So you can use this data
but you usually you cannot run this
models by yourself because it takes a
lot of computational resources.
>> I see. So you you can with that you can
use the idealized or the conceptual
models to get the statistical uh
distribution and compare with the
operational models.
>> Exactly. So what we need to run as a
pseudo observation is completely based
on the idealized model and the ideal
side are very very cheap you know just
like a 10 dimensional stoastic TDS like
40 years only takes maybe 1 minute or
half 30 seconds um we can very long
right then we do this data simulation
but because we do data simulation in the
latent space um we significantly reduce
the dimension if I remember correctly
our eventual dimension will be like um I
think 600 dimensions and we can capture
99% of the expand variance.
So um you know we rely on the simple
model to get the student observation
then we do data simulation we can get
much longer time series then eventually
we do data simulation we can get much
longer spatial temporal patterns and
this long time series or long data set
can help us study a lot of these stream
events or the statistical behavior.
I see. Yeah, I believe this this uh is a
very interesting idea and can be like
generalized to different applications
like what I know from the geo geologist
that oh yeah
>> um they they have like conceptual models
which are like just the channel loops uh
stacking up very quickly um is simulated
in very short time but in the other end
they also have like the so-called
process strategraphy where they simulate
all the sand and mud and loops uh over
years. So I think we have a analogy um
of using your your concept in their
applications. That's why
>> great. Yeah. Thank you. I hope this can
be very useful to other fields.
>> Yeah.
>> And uh we saw one more question from Ju
from in room. So could you say a little
bit more about the improvement in the
Enzo simulation? um is particularly
curious if the model was initialized
once every couple or a few years
>> if the model is initialized. Um no
actually we just do one initialization
then we join it just you know forward
for many years.
So um so the idea is when we do this
oops sorry when we do this learning it's
a method used in the training process.
So basically we use this tool to get a
better forecast model using machine
learning. But once this model is trained
then we just apply this latent space
data simulation. We just keep running it
forward. We start from some arbitrary
initial condition then we can run it for
200 400 years and as long as we have
this 200 400 years data from the
idealized model. So there's no like uh
you know restart processing. So all
these tricks are applied in the training
process once a model trained you just
doing it you know directly without you
know doing any additional things.
>> Hi and thank you for the uh this uh the
answer and I I think I asked you this
question because uh as I know that ENSO
is uh generally known as a kind of
boundary condition issue rather than
initial condition problem. And then uh I
was interested by looking at this that
you have improved this data simulation
which is related to the initial
condition and then ENSO has improved
while the ENSO is you know more
influenced by the boundary condition
than the initial condition. So I I was
wondering that what was the like driver
of this improvement behind of this
>> right yeah good very good a good point.
So ENSO is limited to this specific reg
right. So if we want to run a physical
model or like PD ODS this boundary
conditions are extremely important but
here we just like um this quartile size
system into this grid points. So all
these important boundary effect have
been reflected in the idealized model
setup.
So as long as we can guarantee these
idealized models give us realistic um
simulations then we just need to put
that as suit observations to do the you
know the data simulation. So I guess
what you ask more is about how to um
make sure in the idealized model
framework we can have the correct
physics to make sure we don't have any
you know incorrectness at the boundary.
So that's kind of slightly different
from what we are doing here. So we how
they make sure you know when we build
these idealized models this physics at
the boundaries already good enough. Then
afterwards we just need our operation
models to follow this idealized model
output. So automatically these boundary
conditions are satisfied.
>> Thank you.